we've all been with someone that maybe
you're not the proudest of maybe you
will never ever tell anyone that that
ever happened with that person well
there's also those images there's also
those images online but maybe or maybe
you didn't find something nice about but
you will never tell anyone about that
either don't [ __ ] look at me right
now and tell me that you don't
understand what I'm saying cuz I think a
lot of people understand anyway we're
gonna we're gonna react to some
regrettable porn
[Music]
Dorn
doorknob
lady coming out of the doorknob
[Music]
um doorknob Congrats your pen how can
you find a [ __ ] doorknob sexually the
[ __ ] oh my god apparently it's a huge
thing in Japan what the [ __ ] is this
stop stop this at once
I had no idea well these are all women
doing it I don't see a guy um all right
that's never mind
Oh does it continue yeah it continues
okay but it's fine because he is a very
wonderful person all right even if he
comes home late from work I can endure
it just from his footsteps echoing from
afar I can feel the tension building up
in Mikey
but she oh no stop I don't think I can
read this all right I can't read that
one all right we're just gonna skip that
one cuz [ __ ] rape all right okay so
there's a young boy who pokes whatever
that is of their also doorbells oh so
he's pranking so it's a young boy
ringing on doors as a prank but the
doorbells are women sexism oh we're
getting dirty now
so basically you got excited while
playing a Rogi what's a Rogi okay yogi
is a known for erotic game okay
the more you know and what do you want
from me isn't that obvious
now strip
stop this we are brother and sister
that's just a trivial problem no it's
it's really not it's really not a
trivial right now the most important
process right now right now the most
important problem in the whole world is
to control this global it my boy oh man
I can't what the [ __ ]
Oh God is getting gross now who finds
this someone finds this [ __ ] alright
there you see that's that's my womb well
I'm clearly a fine and healthy woman
aren't I as you can see I've got all the
parts I need to make babies I like that
nice little armpit hair touch oh my god
if you want to translate it for me I'd
be very happy but it starts left with
that what looks like Japanese Thomas a
train I would say in this weird ass
creature next to it and it looks like
he's about to dock with another train
and it looks like he's shooting
something inside probably refilling some
oil and there seems to be an oil leakage
and now there are happy
[Music]
[ __ ] awesome giraffe oh my god no
this is too much I can't what that
[ __ ] hell collection of weird
dialogues and crap impregnate my oh
there it has control this global warming
in my [ __ ] that's a classic that's a
fine classic damn men have different
genitals than I am being [ __ ] by my
own [ __ ]
I can't believe that I Seneca she was I
qiyam that I am completely naked riding
a tricycle she doesn't look very happy
about it
this can't be happen my worst nightmare
being completely naked riding a tricycle
oh she's making so she's animating her
vagina
hello flip i'm oneis cents [ __ ] flat i
don't feel bad at all flap I want you to
put your penis in before isn't it only
sound like little brother or something
don't little don't do that girls don't
do that oh what the [ __ ] you said a
turtle no don't
no no no don't turtle that's impressive
oh my god
nope okay we went through it all this is
really funny I didn't think it would be
this funny and disgusting so there you
go we share this moment together now you
can say that you've seen some regretable
porn with PewDiePie and that's it for me
for now if you enjoyed this video go
ahead and leave a like and subscribe to
become a bro today I will see you and in
tomorrow or something I make a video
every [ __ ] day alright stay awesome
let's take this great picture of Mark
play hmm 43 what the [ __ ] well it looks
like the evidence is pretty clear so far
but let's try some more youtubers let's
try Marcia
[Music]